hi everyone i'm alana and today i am
playing borderlands the pre-sequel at a
preview event here in sydney
borderlands the pre-sequel is a game
that is set between borderlands 1 and 2
so instead of going with borderlands 1.5
they made up their own word because why
not
similar to the others is a first-person
shooter with a bunch of fancy rpg
elements and it really supports co-op
gameplay with the four playable
characters all of whom have existed in
previous games
there's athena claptrap nisha and
wilhelm and i went with wilhelm
so the pre-sequel is set on pandora's
moon and follows the story of handsome
jack from borderlands 2 becoming a
villain but also apparently becoming
handsome because they just refer to him
as jack in this one
you actually start off as one of jack's
henchmen but it's not so bad because he
starts off as a much nicer guy still
kind of arrogant and cheeky and weirdly
lovable but he has some good intentions
and the game follows what went so
horribly wrong to make him an evil
maniac
more importantly though because it's set
on the moon it plays like a super lasery
spacey sci-fi concoction with oxygen
tanks and low gravity environments
this means you get to bounce around
areas shooting glowy lasers at weird
space enemies and it's ridiculous but
awesome there are also freeze weapons
which i found particularly cool which
you can freeze enemies and make them
shatter before you
oxygen tanks are slightly less awesome
because you're in space you can run out
of oxygen
you have to pick up oxygen tanks and
enemies drop or enter a room that might
refill you completely it adds an extra
thing to think about but not one that is
really exciting or really adds to the
gameplay
it's almost just a minor inconvenience
another thing that ought to be mentioned
is claptrap's special ability type thing
which if activated will affect the
entire party
an example of it is that everyone
playing won't be able to stop shooting
if he activates it even if there are no
enemies around meaning you just
basically waste all of your ammo
speaking of funny though the dialogue is
fantastic i had issues with previous
borderlands games being super fetch
questy and it just feels like oh yeah do
this go here do this without a whole lot
of motivation
and while the new one still feels the
same in mission design it's like they've
paid even more attention to having
brilliantly scripted side characters
even ones you might never meet again to
make things consistently amusing no
matter what you're doing
heaps of them are australian too with
actual australian voice actors which is
awesome
borderlands the pre-sequel is set to
release on the 14th of october and is
coming to the xbox 360 ps3 and pc
it's not coming to next-gen consoles at
this point but it may eventually
i guess my initial impression here is
that it's very similar to previous games
it feels much
much more creative and definitely much
more australian which is a nice and
unique touch